[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
have you seen the games releasing
throughout March it's packed to the brim
with retro classics action masterpieces
the spiritual successor to Metal Gear a
few games which will likely go under the
radar and apex legends gets its first
season of content let's go through what
March has to offer I have to start with
the game I'm personally hyped for Devil
May Cry 5 you know Devil May Cry but for
those new to the series DMC follows the
demon murdering skills of professional
devil hunter Dante the series began back
in 2001 so it's understandable that many
people watching now weren't alive back
then
Manimal as you can see Devil May Cry 5
is an adventure style hack and slash
outing but although button bashing can
get you quite far here there's a finesse
to master to get the most out of those
bombastic combos the speed of the action
goes down is or inspiring and makes you
feel like a complete badass for veterans
to the series we know about the
constantly changing playable secondary
characters throughout the last 19 years
from bazooka wielding femme fatales to
the son of your demon twin brother this
time around we meet V but we'll talk
about him later
as I'll be breaking down the story next
week if you want to be fully ready for
release day there's a demo available to
try right now to see if this franchise
is one for you or if it still hits you
in the fields after all these years if
the Resident Evil 2 remake is anything
to go by Capcom are back in a big way in
2019 Devil May Cry 5 releases on March 8
worldwide on ps4 Xbox one and PC on
March 15th the division returns to have
another attempt at an online action RPG
looter shooter set seven months after
the original game this time in
Washington DC in a mission early on
you'll liberate the White House I've
played the private beta and consumed
this game up in a few words more
division if you loved the original or
grew to appreciate the massive
improvements made after many people
moved on then you'll be satisfied by the
division to an open beta begins on March
1st running until the 4th so once again
try it before you buy it
the main issue most people took from the
last game was the lack of endgame
content so Ubisoft massive have made
this their priority keeping gamers happy
long after the campaign credits roll a
new enemy faction
we found character specializations are
unlocked such as bringing a sniper rifle
so powerful it can one-hit most enemies
but the one which piques my interests
are the new raids which can be played by
up to eight players the problem is I
don't know seven people I'd love to know
your thoughts on the division to which
releases on March 15th on ps4 Xbox and
PC when you think of from software what
games brings to mind
Dark Souls or Demon Souls maybe
blood-borne this company's expertise lie
in appealing to the hardcore gamers who
want to challenge the average gamer will
die over 100 times before finishing
anything from from software the latest
title is Sakura shadows die twice set in
sixteenth century Japan the time of the
shinobi you could be expecting a point
system upgrading specific skills and
carefully managing the abilities that
suit your playstyle things are a little
simpler here in Sakura
don't get me wrong though but nothing
near the depth from previous games
allowing us mere mortals to access the
game without feeling overwhelmed the
main focus of Sakura is to use Paris to
break the opponent's posture when this
is done right they become off-balance
for a moment and the opportunity to
strike presents itself making it
possible to end fights in a single blow
if you ever played the tenchu series
you'll be happy to know it's possible to
play large portions of Sakura using
instant stealth kills as long as you
remain unspotted this adds yet another
layer of tactics to the game look for
guard patterns to exploit or rushing
like a madman fight your own way it's
your choice
Sakura shadows die twice releases on
March 22nd on ps4 PC and the Xbox one
here's something which will confuse the
younger members of the audience
toejam Annelle back in the groove
without context I've got to admit this
game looks absolutely terrible but
toejam and earl is steeped in retro
history the game is based on the
original title from back on the Sega
Genesis or Mega Drive over here from
1991 in solo or co-op you'll search the
island for pieces of your broken rocket
ship and then find an elevator to the
next level rinse and repeat the enemies
you face are based on stereotypes from
single mums with crying babies to a
miniature devil they all can kill you
but worse is if they push you to the
side of the map and you fall down a few
levels making regression a real worry in
later stage
falling down five Maps is possible and
bloody heartbreaking the project was
kick-started and ended with over 500
thousand dollars raised to see toejam
and Earl return if you're under 20 years
old here let me know you have thoughts
does this game make any sense to you
toejam and earl back in the groove
releases on March the first on ps4 Xbox
one switch PC and even the market what's
your favorite fighting game you may be
looking forward to Mortal Kombat 11 or
you may be og and like Street Fighter we
all tend to gravitate towards one over
another one which is quietly doing its
own thing is Dead or Alive now on its
sixth iteration right let's quickly get
something out of the way that DOA is
known for boob physics yep they are
still here and still overly bouncy but
underneath that term tessellation is a
very well-put-together fighter
the expansive story mode with branching
options looks like a great deal of fun
with early playtesters incredibly
impressed by the quest mode which breaks
down fights to concentrate on specific
skills quickly rewarded by costume
unlocks and other aesthetic items as you
can tell the character customization is
here and extremely robust but my
favorite part is the slow-motion damage
cinematics and the way the damage
remains on the character throughout the
fight are you thinking about grabbing
Dead or Alive 6 it releases on March the
1st on ps4 Xbox one PC and you'll even
see it bouncing over on arcade - did you
hear about a battle royale game that
appeared with zero fanfare okay so 25
million people downloaded it so I'm sure
you've heard about apex legends well
this overnight behemoth will release its
first season of content in early March
they intend to do this without
advertising so finding information
before the release is close to
impossible what we do know is that the
Battle Pass will be focused around
visual cosmetics keeping the playing
field even - all will see the roster
increased with 11 names found by leakers
but nothing is confirmed just yet in
addition new weapons will release each
and every season a new loot for everyone
season 1 runs for three months making
June the start of the second season the
pricing structure for the Battle Pass
will be a huge indicator as to the
longevity of the product will we see EA
take control and arguably hurt the game
with Faust microtransactions or will
spawn the developers went out and
control their own product
let's hope is the latter we may have
found the spiritual successor to Metal
Gear Solid left alive the front mission
universe has always had a close tie in
with Metal Gear I remember the exclusive
tank decals from Metal Gear Solid Peace
Walker suddenly turning up in front
mission involved but it's not only that
the themes the stealth action the mech
focus are all here in left alive and
with many of the Metal Gear crew working
on left alive it really feels like an
authentic Metal Gear sub story left
alive is essentially a cover shooter
with a heavy focus on survival but it
includes many of the genres to break up
the core gameplay loop the stealth
options in particular can overshadow The
Stand and Deliver gunplay and allows us
to choose our own approach to each piece
of combat there are sections of mech
combat along the way with the story
spanning three characters so the law and
the narrative is constantly added to but
don't worry it's not as convoluted as
Metal Gear well not yet anyway
left alive released in Japan last month
and hits the rest of the world on March
the fifth on ps4 and xboxone here's
something a little different generation
0 the first thing I want to say about
this game is that it's not full price as
you'd expect it's about 60 percent of
what you usually pay generation 0 is an
open world survival outing which can be
played alone or with friends
cooperatively this is a hostile world so
weapons are very important but the love
of exploration is the core value in
battle thin walls can be shot through
making hiding a risky decision keeping
us on edge as a real survival title
shoot missions are given out regularly
to give us direction during the
livestream the squad was asked to
destroy a gas station which alerted
nearby factions which so happened to be
mixed resulting in a tense gunfight
there are two HD re-releases to quickly
note before we end Assassin's Creed 3
which tells a story of how a Native
American played a key role in the birth
of the USA it's more of the Assassin's
Creed you know and love but with
slightly improved visuals releasing on
March 29th the danganronpa trilogy
rounds out the month again releasing on
March 29th as the title suggests it's
three dunk and romper titles in 1 so if
you've been thinking about trying the
series out now is a perfect time
so there we have it 10 games releasing
over March 2019 are you grabbing
anything I'll likely pick up the apex
legends battle pass for season 1 and
second all looks good and Devil May Cry
5 is bloody good job my wallet is going
to hate me I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade it's been an absolute pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]